when NASA scientists started planning  the Curiosity rover mission they knew  they had a problem getting the rover to  Mars was fairly straightforward the  really hard part was EDL entry descent  and landing curiosity waves more than  three tons so happy that the EDL systems  used for earlier missions wouldn't work  so engineers designed a sky crane a  platform with four retro rockets that  would hover above the surface of Mars  Laura Curiosity down on a cable and then  fly away it would have to do it all  automatically because there wouldn't be  time for signals to reach it from Earth  it worked perfectly on August 5th  curiosity landed safe and sound right on  target started studying Mars we don't  know what it's gonna find but the  engineering that got it there was  ingenious enough to rate as one of our  top ten breakthroughs of 2012  you